[Music]
sorry guys I tell you what I have a
better one how about Brendan talking
business
I like it is that better Brandon talking
a little Biz with the boys he's an
entrepreneur bro yeah he sure is you
know what I wish I'd done before Bubba
is I wish um I wish that I had been more
like Rogan in that I got a 200 million
dollar Spotify deal I also wish that I
wish I was more like broken like in the
what meaning like talented or like
memorable right right or like employed
or got good guests yeah
I wasn't as naive
to the consequences of not living
brutally honestly like and more
importantly I wish this is really what I
wish I was I was I came to LA and I was
told Brian just think about acting and
stand up and all the business stuff will
be taken care of by other people
who
never think about business because it'll
get in the way of your art and that was
the dumbest [ __ ] ever I wish somebody
said Brian you are your agent your
manager you you are running your own
business you're the CEO of your own
business work on your brand learn
branding learn business stop saying it's
not for you yeah because why were you
like randomly starting fist fights in
bars like man I get it but dude you're
the angriest dude I know and you almost
and you almost had [ __ ] Bobby Lee
swatted you know and what really really
what I wrestle with every day is having
to read your sexuality because of those
sandals we learn or at least or at least
redefine that from the idea now he's
like a 65 year old woman he does sit
like kind of like a girl both of them do
my brain so I wish I wish I had been I
wish I'd been way more paranoid of
people yeah and I know you feel that way
too
you're right though why do they cross
their legs it's never been a comfortable
position because I don't know man maybe
therapy dicks or balls I know but no
Brandon has a big dick he only mentioned
it 33 times and it's 25 Minutes special
he doesn't have that big of a dick if
he's Crossing his legs like that's a
comfortable normal yeah position for you
to be and you don't have a pig or or
even balls like even a decent because
your balls
yeah you've always feel that I've always
been like you've been way better I've
been way better as far as the market and
run my own business and he's great he's
been the best guy at being marketing and
running his own business
he's been crushing it unless you ask his
peers people who like comedy people who
hate comedy people like UFC people who
hate UFC besides them though he's
killing it um
did not rely on managers in the agents
oh and also no you rely on a [ __ ]
steroid-induced gay lion instead
sounds good people people too I think
I'm too I was always too trusting yeah
and I would never say Brian Callan is
too trusting everyone always told me
including you but especially like my
clothes my all the people that really
know my problem is that I love too much
yeah I care too much
family members were like you bring you
bring in way too much of the broken and
crazy yeah you waste your time on it
Brennan he's talking about you
wasted my time but uh but now yeah you
and I are Polar Opposites when it comes
to that stuff like obviously business
side of things that's what I like to do
so
he's a [ __ ] he's a businessman it's
just it's the way he Hypes he Hypes
himself up like it's weird right like he
every time Brandon talks it's him
convincing himself of something I'm a
businessman I'm really good at business
I'm such a you're such a good
businessman that the guy that you let
run your whiskey brand on Instagram got
it banned no good businessman would
allow that like do you understand you're
such a good businessman that your quote
unquote Handler is still starting fights
with like field Vaughn and [ __ ] in
kalila and [ __ ] for no reason bringing
you more [ __ ] that you don't need so
stop stop pretending you're a good
businessman you're not okay good
businessmen don't have to do well first
off good Comics don't have to do five
takes to do a 25 minute special but good
businessman would see all the downvotes
and go wow this didn't work maybe I'll
try something new instead of Leaning
into being a fake a being a dumb fake
comedic wannabe Mexican which is weird I
believe that and you had a meeting last
night with my management and agents I'm
tired cool who's your management man
because I do everything myself I'm tired
he's tired he does everything himself
he's a sleepy boy he's tired he's so
hard it's so difficult it's so [ __ ]
difficult
what do you do bro you do podcasts so do
I what are you [ __ ] talking about
what's so hard and also what do you do
running your business you basically just
delegate everything right yeah I mean
seriously what are you printing the
t-shirts yourself in your garage like
you know what I mean are are you are you
showing the pants you sell like what are
you distilling the whiskey in a bathtub
in your spare bedroom
like what are you doing you're slapping
your dumb thick boy name on [ __ ] so I
told him I said you know I'm I'm it's
not that I'm
relinquishing power but I could use some
help I told him that I could use some
help
letting other people help you it's a
trust thing it's it's also a really the
only reason you exist is because Rogan
helped you
so don't act like you're I don't like
help I don't like a hand up Showtime
special unearned Showtime special
probably very important yes yeah if you
look at people that really have big you
can only get so far in your you can only
get so far yeah that's what I said last
night I said I'm I've learned the hard
way I'm tired man like I can't is there
any way other than that to learn is
there have you ever learned anywhere
anyway other than the hard way because
me neither I'm tired man guys he's tired
he's like The Rock he can print himself
to The Croc Rock the last video that we
watched to him him and The Rock have the
same work ethic they're the same guy
basically basically I just put it in
Show links why he's so tired it's uh
that's his the mark Harley and him had a
weekend
oh here it is this is why he's so tired
Jesus that's why he's so tired
that's not uh I can't prove it that's
not them we don't know it's Mark Carly
right there
tired so hopefully we can help out and
if not all good so there's someone who
can you know maybe it's not them but
hopefully it is but that's why I told
last night I said I'm finally ready to
admit and give you guys your percentage
I'm tired I need help man wouldn't you
say that work all this stuff to stand up
it's a lot man wouldn't you say that I
would say this like finding really
people that are really good at their
jobs even if it's menial or even if it's
a smaller job is like gold it's like
finding [ __ ] gold people that give a
[ __ ] about themselves that's fine yeah
people really want to work hard for you
Brandon it really Inspire confidence in
people what are you going to buy them
all hammocks like Homer did for Real
Jesus Christ oh that's also on third
it's in the hammock District you know
and not just ride the wave what that's
why Chin's so good try finding on the
chin go ahead good luck I could find
chins everywhere you're in California
there's chins all over the place and
chongs and Changs
are they Youngs are they you no no that
doesn't mean chin or Mark yeah both of
them are Mark yeah I didn't call Market
two in the morning yep
why are you hauling your producer at two
in the morning and why is Mark answering
talk okay just to see how things are
just yeah hey yeah what's up boss you
know what's funny calling to see what
are you what are you thinking about and
We Know by the way we know they watch
our videos because Brian kind of let it
slip a couple years ago that they do and
you know
um so I know they watched this and I
gave you this two in the morning like
shoes referring to the disguise again
the [ __ ] making fun of me now bro and
then you know you know you guarantee
your Market is like I could take it bro
don't worry about it man let him come
after me you do your thing dude that's
what I'm here for I'm here to take the
heat That's What I Am The Shield you're
the sword bro
oh that made me cringe don't see that
really but you know what he would say
that he would say that Mark Carly would
say that for sure
I'll do the dental Jam to your moist
vagina Brendan okay there's [ __ ]
definitely a better way to say it than
that it was anyway any other way would
have been better than that how did the
dental dance of your butthole Brandon no
no that's not the problem okay
I got done with that meeting yesterday
Mark's the first person I called so what
do you think that's what they think I
should do okay I think you could use
some help dude that's why so Mark's
advice Mark's advice to you was
I think you some help dude and also
are you noticing that
Brennan has been pushing mark down
callan's throat a lot like every time we
play a clip he's bringing he's bringing
mark on and being like isn't he cool
isn't he awesome oh yeah it's it's like
the chick who's like you're gonna love
my boyfriend he's awesome right he's
never awesome
I said between the whiskey the network
stand up the merch
uh all these other branding deals it's
like I'm tired man I'm trying to make a
new Instagram there has to be somebody
you can handle this one all right hey
let me give you some great hey man I'm
really tired bro like I'm [ __ ]
exhausted like Mark what should I do I
don't really hired help I guess yeah
probably get somebody better than me to
run Instagram accounts I've burned
through two of your accounts bro and I'm
actively fighting with people on Reddit
I'm probably not the person to be doing
this yeah if anything frankly I'm
probably a liability yeah I'd fire me
that's my advice that would be the best
advice I'd fire me be honest with you
I said I'm [ __ ] tired we've been
telling this for years I went I know but
you're basically uh you're basically a
coal miner
to be fair I don't think I would have
gone as far as I did if I had depended
on you guys I said I'm ready to give up
whatever it is maybe doing it on your
own you had to do it on your own so you
could see what you can't do on your own
wow
you guys are pretty pretty stupid huh
it's this
how do you try to feign machismo
but dress like a bunch of metrosexuals I
don't get it how do you try to be a
tough guy but then tell me about your
therapy session it can't be both right
tough guy in capri pants yeah said
nobody ever